[拍手]
愛嬌大学のヤシのですよろしくお願いします
今日話はまあ祭神のついて知ることを伝えることということを題してお話をしに来まし
た
あの
再生医療という言葉の皆さんご存知かと思いますあの
なんか日本橋っていうのは先ほどあの
女将さんが出てきて服を着ている伝統のある場所それはもちろんあの
日本橋正しい姿なんですけど実はここにいらっしゃる方皆さんご存知かもしれません
けど
日本橋は前川ん
ヘッド
本場所はあの
沢山のメガファーマの候補者なんかもあります
実は私が入っております日本再生医療学会事務局っていうのも日本橋ありまして週に一
回ぐらい
場所に来て
再生医療
まあ失敗知ってるよーっていうような方もいっぱいいらっしゃると思うんですけれども
ただそれってどういう事を知っていらっしゃるでしょうか
山中伸弥教授のノーベル賞
今まで出来なかった秒息が治るようになるいろんなことをしていらっしゃると思うん
ですけれども
ただ本当にそれ知っているということなんでしょうか
何で私がこうやって再生ので知ってほしいのかこういうことを方に浸りはなのかという
ことです
例えば ips 細胞っていうものが山中伸弥教授が作ったの日でしょう
それがベースなで最終ができるんだということが言われていると思いますが
ただまあそれについて
いろんな問題がリスます例えば安全性はどうなのかとか
まあいろんな人が言及したかどんな研究しているのかそれからまあ悪用されたりしない
のか様々なことについて
考えてみるといっぱい金もが湧いてくると思います
わからないことたくさんあるけれどもまあ再生医療の研究
1研究者の人専門家が一生懸命やってくれているから専門家に任せておけばいいだろう
新しい病気が治るになった時はきっとお医者さんが勝手に提供してくれに違いないって
いうふうに思っていらっしゃると思うんですね
もちろん世の中の研究者夜中のお医者さんは一生懸命直そうと思って
研究をしています治療をやってますだけど本当にそれだけで信用していいのかっていう
ことをもういっぺん考えてほしいなっていうのがあって今日話にしに来ています
もしも再生医療というものが自分が受けてみようと思ったときに
受けた結果
何かを言う外のことが起こったあるいは治らなかった
もしかしたらすごく高いお金を食べられるかもしれないそんなことになった時には
やっぱり
知らない事っていうのが再生の対する過剰な失望っていうのはそういうのはまず寝
ちゃうんじゃないかっていうのを我々研究者中はすごく寄港しているんですね
でまぁ再生医療が期待をされるようなた背景っていうのはこのグラブがありますがまぁ
現在2000円18年現在平均寿命だいたい日本人の場合はですね
ここに書いてあるように男性ですと80歳ぐらい女性ですと86歳ぐらいなんですがに
全60年くらいになるとも女性は
記述さ聞こえてくるんですね
こういうなまあ高齢化社会というのを今迎えていますね
うんかー最初に国勢調査が始まったぐらいの明治初年度くらいというのは日本人の平均
寿命だいたい40歳前後です
つまり150年くらいの間で日本人の平均寿命っていうのがだいたい
倍になって生きてる時間が倍になっているということなんです
倍になっているということは何が起こってくるかということです
私たちの体の中にいっぱい細胞にダメージが溜まってくるんですね
元気な細胞がいます
元気な細胞普通であればまあ
元気に割られのパラダの中で役目を果たしてくれるんですけれども
ひとたびそれが
ストレスが溜まり始めるとですねどんどんどんどん体の中で
影響が溜まってきてストレスが蓄積されていって驚いてしまいます
最終的には
その細胞というのはもう戻れなくなってしまいます
まあ
印刷物のコピーを繰り返すコピーマ o コピーって繰り返していくと最初は鮮明に
読めていた文字がだんだん見えなくなる
ちっちゃいホコリがついていたのがどんどんその誇りが大きくなってなんかゴミがもう
どんどん見えなくなっていってしまう
そういうことになってくるというのが細胞の中でも起こっています
そうなると細胞の役目は果たせなくなってしまって最終的には病気になる
でそうなってしまうと
取り返すことができない持っ
狂ってしまったコピーしか体の中に存在しなくなればそこから守ることはできないわけ
です
再生医療研究って何をしようとしているかというとそのようにしてまー狂ってしまった
細胞を割れてしまった細胞というのを
直そうというものです今までですと機械を使う例えば人工透析のようなものをそれから
増給食でのものを使う
またインシュリンのような形で外側から何かを補充するということで失った機械の失い
た細胞の役割を果たそうと
現在であればそういうふうにしていたものを
例えば心臓の細胞だとか筋肉の細胞形成期の細胞からだの中で病気になってしまった
細胞自体を身体の外で作って移植をしてやろうというのがまあ細胞治療ということに
なって
要するにこれまでであると症状に対してその場しのぎというか
対症療法であったものが
この方法を使うと
まあ今家に近い状況を持っていけるということになるわけです
このような形で再生医療というのが合同高齢化社会の中ですごく期待をされ始めてい
現在行っているのはどんな細胞を出発点にしてどんな方法で細胞を作ってあればいいの
かそしてどういう方法を使って体の中に入れてやればいいのかそういうことの研究って
いうのが盛んになされている状況です
でまぁ皆さんにとって一番なじみがあってね作家の名前を出してますけれども私の所属
している研究所の所長会で山中伸弥教授山中教授が ips 細胞を作るということで
まぁ
ノーヴェ小銃されましたこの新聞
いくつか出ていますけれども ips 細胞を作成されている実現に満ちということ
書いてあります
ただ十分点はですねこれ山中教授官能描写もらったのは
2013年のことですが
2012年のことですけれども山中教授がノーベル賞もの時にはまだひとつの細胞も
人間のカードに移植されていない
再生医療として ips タイプがまだ1回も使われていない状況であれはノーベル賞
受賞しました
つまり彼がのオペレーションもらった時というのが
まず基礎的な研究生物学の研究として非常に重要な功績を残したということでノーベル
賞貰っていますですので決して再生医療を実現させたからということでさえ基調を
もらったということではないんですね
山中教授一生懸命ノーベル賞の後も研究をして
人間の中で細胞を使って治療ができないかということを研究してきました
色づいて情報発信していますたい制御 ips 細胞研究についてお話をしてきました
そういうこともあってですね再生医療研究に対する一般市民の調査というの私ども行っ
たんですがここで出てきたのは再生医療研究の推進に対して一般の人たちは非常に高い
支持率を保っています7割以上の人が再生医療研究推進していく
えっ
自分たちの細胞を使って研究をしてくれという人もたくさんいるということです
そういう状況において再生医療というのは非常に信頼されているんですが
ただその機体を使ってお金儲けをしようとする人たちも少なからずいます
再生を使ったホームページ再生医療について宣伝するホームページというのは実際日本
に限らず世界的な問題になっています
これちょっと古くなります2008年のデータですけれども再生医療研究ラっていう
再生医療の治療をやっているっていうことを線電車のホームページ
それを調べるとですねいかにもその治療方法っていうのが安全で有効性が区立
ていて
何でも聴きますよいうことを歌ってるホームページは本当にたくさんあります
そういうところいうのを判断する知識っていうのは一般の日立はなかなか売ってないと
いう状況がありますですので患者さんあるいは社会というのが十分かつ適切な情報を得
られ
でていないその状況において
数の危険にさらされず可能性があるというのを研究者がは本当にへ寄付をしてきました
そうした背景のもとですね2013年に日本では再生医療を推進する効率というのが
整備されました
この法律っていうのは再生医療
国の方針として国の政策として
研究をしていこうそしてそれを普及させていこうということを決めた法律です
再生医療の推進ということを歌っている法律というのは実は世界の中でもほとんど例が
ありませんでした
再生医療製品の実用化を促進する仕込みでとかそれから再生医療のお届けで登録制度を
つくるっていうことがこの法律書かれているんですが
この法律ができることで実はアメリカなんかも日本の制度
取り組んで新しく再生を推進するための制度オバマ時代に作りました
ただそうした方があった背景で新しい法律ができたにもかかわらずこれ新聞につい最近
載った記事ですので皆さんをご覧になった後も以来
たと思いますけれどもまあ違法に細胞移植をするっていうことをやってしまう国が
たくさんあったということなんですね
まあこの背景に何があったかというとやはり再生医療に対する大きな期待があるという
ことです
今のような細胞の移植っていうのはどういう状況で行われているかというとまあ我々
研究者なんかやっている例えば論文の中でこうしたものがでもできるようになりました
それがプレスリリースを通じて新聞なんかでこんな形で使えるになりましたと言うよう
な事が書かれることがあると思いますただその時点っていうのまだ出発点にすぎません
細胞レベルでの安全
性有効性を確認するあるいは動物で有効性安全性を確認するということを得ないといけ
ません
まあその段階はが本当の最初の段階ですこういう段階のことを前臨床試験といって人間
じゃない東京で安全性を確認していますその後初めて人間に投与するということが行わ
れます
一番最初の段階は有効性を見るものではありません一番最初にあるのは安全性の確認
です
動物で何もなかったただ人間にを消耗すると音が起こってしまうということは実は曲の
中ではよくあることなんですね
なのでまず人間で安全性を確認したければならないただこのときに有効性が掃除で確認
できる場合もあります
そうなるとですねやはり治療に早く使いたいというお医者さんなんかも出てきます
そういうようなお医者さんがただ出てきた場合には
治療としてお医者さんが投票するということが日本の法律はできるようになっています
こうした状況のことをどういうかというと自由診療という風に言っています
here とエヴァ
国の中のお役所旺盛労働省とかそういうところが有効数
見たわけじゃないんですね
ですので口には有効性を確認していないからいわゆる保険治療という形で商品はされて
いません
こういうふうに商品をされていないと彼等のと日本の中では保険治療としては使えない
はれ3割負担でできないという状況です
現在日本で保険が使える再生医療製品で実際4つしかないんですね
心筋梗塞の時に使う細胞シート真騎士というのがありますし
軟骨の資料な間柄もそれからバイオした皮膚を使ってやけどなをすっぽり等については
再生医療として認められています
現在最新論座
だいたい1段階というのはこういう段階にあります先ほどと同じく
前臨床試験というものをやっている細胞というのはたくさんありますが
この安全性次試験に行くまでにもなかなかやはりハードルが高いです
維持さ安全性試験が行われているものも多々出始めていますし
有効性試験という何回にっぽんどもあります一つ大事な点としてはこれ人間に対してお
医者さんが細胞を投与してますけれどもこれ治療ではありません
あくまで臨床試験と言われている研究の段階です
ここまでがすべて国の承認を受けるための研究として必要なプロセスなんですね
これをやることによってようやく日本は有効性安全性を確認して
保険治療という形で
3割負担低提供することができるなります
x2の開発の場合ですと
前臨床試験でだいたい3年から5年
臨床試験で3年間7面そして審査で1年かかるということで
新聞に載った治療法新聞に載った有望な結果というのがお
一般の人たちのテンポとブログまでは10年近いそういうのは普通にかかるわけです
ですので
自由診療として行われるものっていうのが果たして本当に有効なものかどうかというの
がです
広く確認されているわけではないということについて我々は勝たなければならない
けれど
繰り返しなりますけれどもこの臨床試験という段階はお医者さんが行っているもので
あるので治療と混同されがちですがこれは治療ではありませんなのでたとえば臨床研究
あるいは知見というものを受けようという時に判断するときにですね
治るかもしれないという風に考えてそれを受けてしまうと
期待とそれから実際に提供されてものギャップというのが非常に大きくなってしまう
これは実はセラピューティックミスコンセプションと言って世界的にも大きな問題と
なっています
また私たち研究所の皮が再生の柱で語りたい
みんなに知ってもらいたいと思っていることをそして
社会の側がこういうことを知りたいと思っていることの間にギャップがあるということ
も私たちの調査でわかってきました
例えば危険性新しい治療を自己負担額そうしたもの一般の方々は知りたいと思ってい
ますけれども私たち研究者はそれがまだ実用段階に届いていないことがわかっているの
で
そんなことを話してもしょうがないだろうまず科学的にどうなんだということを
しゃべらなければいけない
メカニズムの話をしなければいけない科学的にこれから同機体があるのかということ
話したいつまり夢があることいっぱい話したいというふうに思ってしまうんですね
そういうところから
やはり社会の側というのは最初に対して非常に大きな期待を持ってしまうというそう
いう危険性があるかという風にも
アリアたら最後にお話をして売ったりということはやはり社会のがはもう新しい治療法
に釣り知るということがとても大事だということ
先ほど言ったような臨床試験そして自由心情というものがある
じゃあ自分たちがこれから受けようとしているのはどういうものなのかということを
考えないと例えばこのように菊花期間か分からないけれども目新しい話お金を儲けよう
と思っているそうした人たちにつけ込む隙を与えてしまいます
ですので私が皆さんにお伝えしたい事を競ってぜひ知っておいてもらいたいこととして
は自分が受けようとしているものはどういう段階のものなのか
そしてどういう仕組みで病気が治るとしているのか
どんな危険性があってどうやって安全性を確保しているのかそして自分の民何かあった
ときにそのお医者さんがどういう対応してくれるのかということを知ってほしいと言う
やはり現在研究の現場とそれから
一般の社会というのが結びつかなければ新しい治療法新しい時代というのを作っていけ
ないと思っています
ここに書いてありますように現在
医療研究を取り巻く環境というのは様々に変わってきています個人が絡むものも
たくさん出てきていますしお金がかかるものお金が高額なもの
そして製品化するときにお金が互いにかかるものいろんなものが出てきています
そういう状況において研究を進めていくには最後に何が大事かというとそれは研究の
現場が社会から信用してもらうことです
このように信頼をしてもらう社会と一緒に新しい時代を作っていく
こうした研究については現在ヨーロッパを中心に入っているのが責任ある研究
レスポンシブリサーチアンドイノベーション rri と呼ばれているものがあります
我々研究者の側もこうしたものを考えていかなければなりませんけれどもぜひ皆様の
ですね
献金についてみんな真面目にやってるからヒア前世が一生懸命話してるから寄付し
なきゃそういうことだけではなくてその中身についてぜひ
議員にしながら考えるということをしてくださいという形で私たち研究者だけじゃなく
て社会と一緒に新しい剤を作っていければそういうふうに思っています
まあこのような形でまぁお話をさせて頂きか言ってもなかなかないんですけれどもぜひ
日本橋というそのライフサイエンスのハブになっていくかもしれないそうした場所で
ever 伝統と一緒に社会と一緒に新しい未来をつくっていければと思っていますご
静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]